لا مكان للطالبات في الجامعات الافغانيه
فللمره الاولى منذ 22 عاما تمنع الطالبات
من الالتحاق بمقاعد الدراسه جامعه كابول
الاعرق والاقدم في افغانستان خلت من
الطالبات وحتى من جئنا للاحتجاج مضينا بكل
هدوء خوفا من الاعتقال والمساءله
رحاب يرداري عاشت طفولتها في عمان والدوحه
وبعد وفاه والدها الدبلوماسي السابق اكملت
الثانويه العامه في كابول وسنتها الجامعيه
الاولى في العلوم السياسيه اليوم تسعى
جاهده للخروج من بلدها لاكمال مشوارها
التعليمي انا عندي خطط الحصول على منح
وذهب الى خارج البلاد لانه الان لا استطيع
اكمال دراسه داخل البلاد مع ذلك حتى ذهب
والسفر الى خارج البلاد اصبح صعبا لان
كوني فتاه لو اريد الذهاب الى السفر احتاج
الى محرم
سعديه سعيد من اوائل الطالبات اللاتي
خرجنا من كابول بعد قرار الحكومه
الافغانيه حضر تعليم الفتيات
بعد قرارات الحكومه المشرفه ضد الطالبات
خرجت مباشره الى تركيا حصلت على قبول
جامعي صحيح اواجه الان بعض المشاكل
الماليه لانني لم احصل على منحه دراسيه
رغم ذلك انا محظوظه لانني غادرت افغانستان
بعد الطالبات الجامعات الخاصه اكبر
الخاسرين
فاستثماراتها الماليه على شفل انهيار بسبب
الاجراءات الحكوميه جامعه السلام تواجه
مصيرا مجهولا رغم فصلها بين الجنسين في
المباني والتوقيت منذ تاسيسها قبل 14 عاما
جامعه سلام هي خسرت
اكثر من 56% من طلابها لان هذا هذه النسبه
كانت تشكلها البنات في هذه الجامعه وبذلك
نحن نواجه في هذا هذه السنه الدراسيه
اكثر من خمسين بالمئه خساره في موازنتنا
ويبدو ان قرار منع الفتيات من التعليم وما
تلاه من ارتدادات داخليا وخارجيا اضحى
موضوع خلاف داخل الحكومه الافغانيه
النقطه الوحيده التي تركز عليها كل وسائل
الاعلام هي موضوع تعليم الفتيات لكنهم لا
ينظرون لوضع افغانستان وما تعانيه يركزون
على رغباتهم ويتساءلون لماذا تم اغلاق
الجامعات امام الفتيات يقومون بالتشويش
على الناس هذا ظلم وليس عدلا
ورغم كل الضغوط السياسيه والاقتصاديه
وانتقادات المجتمع الدولي لقرار حظر تعليم
الفتيات تسر الحكومه الافغانيه على التمسك
بموقفها ستخلو حجرات الدراسه من الفتيات
في افغانستان لاجل غير مسمى ومع تمسك
الحكومه بقرارها لا تملك الطالبات الا
مواصله دراستهن خارج البلاد وهو خيار اقرب
الى الطرف منه الى الضروره ناصر شديد
الجزيره من جامعه كابول